live aus köln der presseclub mit jörg
schönenborn herzlich willkommen schön
dass sie dabei sind an diesem
sonntagmittag es hat eine gewisse
tradition neuen regierungen 100 tage
schonfrist zu geben dass man ihre arbeit
beurteilt das geht übrigens auf den
amerikanischen präsidenten franklin d
roosevelt zurück der sein amt mitten in
der schwersten wirtschaftskrise 1933
übernahmen und die presse im weißen haus
bat gebt mir 100 tage bis er meine new
deal meine wirtschafts gesetzgebung
beurteilt
unsere regierung ist elf tage im amt und
sie hat gleich zwei schwere krisen mit
denen sie sich beschäftigen muss corona
und die außenpolitische zuspitzung mit
russland das wird daraus fortschritt und
aufbruch der uns versprochen wurde
bleibt raum dafür in der politik unser
presseclub thema heute neue regierung
alte probleme wie viel aufbruch bringt
die ampel und ich freue mich auf diese
gäste daniel brössler ist bei uns berlin
korrespondent der süddeutschen zeitung
herzlich willkommen robin alexander
stellvertretender chefredakteur der welt
ich begrüße kerstin münstermann sie
leitet das parlamentsbüro der
rheinischen post in berlin und tina
hildebrandt ist wieder bei uns
chefkorrespondentin der wochenzeitung
die zeit
hildebrandt elf tage im amt ein satz zur
ampel ein gedanke eine beobachtung wenn
ich muss sagen die ampel hat sich im
wortsinn unwahrscheinlich viel
vorgenommen also so viel wie sie
wahrscheinlich kaum schaffen wird und
das ist auch gut so das ist gut dass sie
sich sehr viel vorgenommen hat weil
darin im grunde die idee steckt dass
politik wirklich einen unterschied
machen kann und sich nicht sozusagen
immer verkrümeln muss vor den
sachzwängen und problemen die von außen
einprasseln und das finde ich gut
münstermann einem satz ein gedanke zur
ampel ein interessantes politisches
wagnis würde ich sagen und ich glaube
dass es ein kanzler olaf scholz gibt der
vielmehr als moderator auftreten wird in
den kommenden vier jahren der drei
partner untereinander
basler einsatzbeamte ist aus der not
geboren kann aber funktionieren muss in
gewisser hinsicht funktionieren weil der
neuen sich kai timm parteien system
entspricht die großen volksparteien
werden wir so nicht mehr sehen und da
werden solche drei parteien
konzentrationen einfach die neue
normalität sein alexander ist der hat
diese regierung sich sehr auf ihre
biologie konzentriert und sehr viel
andere eigene inszenierung nach außen
gedacht und wenn jetzt die
herausforderung von außen kommen dann
steht der test an was sie können und was
nicht auch schon mal eine regierung so
vom start weg gefordert die pandemie
möglicherweise jetzt mit einer neuen
welle die zuspitzung der krise mit
russland das für einen staat eine
ungewöhnliche situation
naja politik ist ja keine 100 meter lauf
bei den olympischen spielen also man
kann ja nicht sagen die weltlage zum
innehalten weil wir eine neue
bundesregierung wählen und beide krisen
waren absehbar also beide krisen sind
nicht über nacht hereingebrochen
und darum ist es schon interessant weil
wir haben ja beide in beiden krisen
balkone im wahlkampf unterschiedliche
positionen vertreten also fast diametral
diebe grünen könnte es nicht scharf
genug sein die fdp hat das lied der
freiheit gesungen bei russland sind in
dieser koalition die leute in einer
regierung die sagen man sollte am besten
organisch auf putin reagieren und
frieden signal senden und die leute die
im wahlkampf noch zur front gefahren
sind sich mit helmen und fotografieren
ließen und waffenlieferungen fordert
also dass die da so unsortiert
hineingehen hat auch ein bisschen mit
ihnen selbst zu tun danke dass sie dabei
sind auch in den sozialen netzwerken wir
verfolgen über presseclub und tagesschau
was sie schreiben was sie uns
zurückmelden und ich versuche mal nach
dieser runde ein bisschen zu sortieren
wir haben das thema pandemie wir haben
die krise mit russland und wir haben das
versprechen des koalitionsvertrags
lassen sie uns das in der reihe
abarbeiten frau hildebrandt lassen sie
uns mit der pandemie situation anfang
ein neuer gesundheitsminister eine
regierung die einen neuen stil
versprochen hat was ändert sich jetzt in
der pandemie politik wird jetzt alles
besser naja erstmal musste sozusagen die
ampel regierung auf die höhe der zeit
kommen es muss man sagen sie ist ja
dahin geraten in die pandemie und würde
allerdings zur verteidigung sagen wir
hatten ja eine regierung also es ist ja
viel kritisiert worden dass die ampel zu
spät war ich finde das gilt für den
kanzler ich finde da hätte sich früher
zu wort melden müssen aber auf der
gesetzgeberischen und maßnahmen ebene
hatten wir die sogenannte geschäfts für
eine regierung die eine regierung war
und bis zum letzten tag im amt hätte
handeln können und müssen ich finde die
aufregung um dieses nachgebesserte
infektionsschutzgesetz und die
beendigung der pandemischen lage ist das
war symbolisch doch es war kein gutes
signal das heißt hat der ampel auch
schwer geschadet es war aber im prinzip
reparabel und ist ja dann auch repariert
worden ich glaube man muss sich auch
davon verabschieden dass so schlimm zu
finden das repariert wird weil das wird
ein dynamisches geschehen bleiben wo man
immer wieder reagieren und reparieren
muss und immerhin hat die ampel einige
maßnahmen getroffen nämlich 3g am
arbeitsplatz und vor allem die
überprüfung der regeln das überprüfen
der regeln in dem staatsunternehmen bahn
die zwei jahren nicht möglich war die es
vorher nicht gegeben hat
ich glaube das ist schon mehr sind als
nur anfangsschwierigkeiten ich glaube
dass sich hier gerade zeigt dass mit der
fdp eine partei der regierung ist die
einfach aus einer ganz anderen richtung
kommt die wahlkampf damit gemacht hat
wir brauchen die freiheit zurück und die
jetzt einfach zeigen muss wie tarieren
wir freiheit aus mitverantwortung und es
zeigt sich gerade in der diskussion um
die impfpflicht dass hier der riss
mitten durch die fdp geht das heißt wir
haben eine koalition die rücksicht
nehmen muss auf die fdp und eine fdp die
eigentlich in dieser frage nicht
wirklich sortiert ist und die auch
ziemliche konflikte wird austragen
müssen das wird glaube ich jetzt wenn
wir die mikrowelle kommen sehen wir für
die fdp leicht noch für die ganze
koalition sei ja ich würde dem
widersprechen ich glaube dass die ampel
schon einen großen fehler gemacht hat am
anfang weil sie es einfach ausgeblendet
haben sie wollten einen politischen
erfolg über die letzte regierung das
haben sie irgendwie durch gesetz zu
einer zeit wo man schon sagen konnte da
kommt vielleicht was und jetzt finde ich
sehr interessant wie der neue
gesundheitsminister der zum team
vorsicht gehört erklären will dass die
niederlande omikron in einen völligen
lockdown über weihnachten gehen während
wir hier so tun als sei alles noch toll
weil die instanzen ein bisschen zurück
gehen am dienstag soll sich der
expertenrat omikron äußern und wenn karl
lauterbach die linie verfolgt die
us-wissenschaftler hatte muss er
eigentlich vor weihnachten zu seinem
kanzler gehen und sagen wir kommen so
nicht über die feier und die silvester
tage also ich glaube die ampel hat hier
ein lackmustest den sie bisher nicht gut
besteht und die idee dass herr kiener
hat jetzt sagt impfpflicht ich weiß
nicht so ganz der spd generalsekretär
herr kubicki seines zeichens
bundestags-vizepräsident sich dagegen
äußert es gibt anträge gegen diese
impfpflicht ich glaube da haben wir im
neuen jahr sofort als stimmt aber es ist
eine handlungs und er ist sozusagen
objektiv anerkannt das ist eine
impfpflicht geben muss und je mehr also
je schwieriger die frage ist haben wir
genug impfstoffe und wie wirken die
einfach eigentlich umso schwieriger wird
es natürlich dass viele gründe insofern
finde ich ist die fdp die ja sonst gerne
in der außenseiterposition ist in dieser
impfpflicht debatte ist das natürlich
eine debatte die nicht nur quer durch
die koalition jetzt sondern auch durch
die bevölkerung das sehen wir ja ständig
das ist ja eine hoch
aufgeladene debatte und man sieht an dem
verlauf der debatte wie das immer hin
und her schwankt erst keine impfpflicht
alle haben das versprochen dann waren
sozusagen gefühlt alle schon auf der
linie die vernünftige position ist die
impfpflicht und jetzt wird das gerade
wieder ein bisschen in frage gestellt
also insofern ist das auch eine chance
weil die wortmeldungen von kubicki und
hat nichts gutes erwarten lassen weil
das ja keine ruhige debatte sondern er
sagt das ist das ist eigentlich ein
rachedurst wäre an sich haben impfen
lassen und und jetzt unbedingt die
impfpflicht durchsetzen wollen das ist
jetzt nicht die ruhige diskussionen die
man sich eigentlich wünschen müsste in
dieser neuen ich bin gar nicht die disco
schritt gegen die diskussion ich bin
auch nicht dagegen dass sie laut ist nur
eine regierung muss eine position haben
eine regierung muss eine mehrheit haben
und die impfpflicht ist die erste
entscheidende frage dieser regierung und
olaf scholz hat keine kanzlermehrheit
stellen sie sich mal vor gerd schröder
hätte das so gemacht damals gab es im
kosovo-krieg wahnsinnig schwierig für
rot grün und schröder hat über fischer
die grünen gezwungen ihre position zu
klären und hat gesagt das muss ein
eigener mehrheit entschieden werden
scholz sagt ja wir machen gruppenanträge
das fand ich allerdings gerne merkel in
der euro rettung merkel hätte in der
euro-rettung immer eine mehrheit gehabt
mit der spd auch in schwarz gelben
zeiten hat aber darauf bestanden dass
die spd das mitträgt weil sowas heißt ja
halb kanzlermehrheit und das soll es ist
einfach und ich finde auch das
kontrastiert scharf zum
selbstbewusstsein der ampel die ampel
sagt wir sind das bündnis dass
fortschritt die union wird überstimmt
rechts an den rand gedrängt und zu afd
und in der ersten materiellen frage sind
sie gar nicht beieinander also da ist
anspruch und wirklichkeit
ein muss ist vielleicht das größte
problem aus sicht der bürgerinnen und
bürger in der pandemie ist die
verunsicherung über ständig wechselnde
positionen entscheidungen empfehlungen
natürlich viel damit zu tun haben dass
pandemien schlecht berechenbar sind ganz
sicher ist die erwartungen an die neue
regierung hier mehr klarheit sie haben
jetzt verschiedene fragen aufgeworfen
der lock down in den niederlanden großes
thema auch bei unseren rückmeldungen im
netz das thema impfstoff das thema
impfpflicht lassen sie das uns
nacheinander abarbeiten thema
impfpflicht
die spd gesundheitspolitische sprecherin
im bundestag hat gesagt wie kann man
eine impfpflicht verabschieden wenn man
nicht mal genau weiß wann und in welchem
abstand eigentlich geimpft werden muss
war es voreilig die impfpflicht zu
fordern so wie es voreilig war sie vor
anderthalb jahren auszuschließen
ich finde es ist eine legitime position
für eine impfpflicht zu sein aber es ist
natürlich trotzdem begründungspflicht
ich finde übrigens dass das mit sehr
guten gründen das bin ich so ein
bisschen altes denken die
kanzlermehrheit also ich finde an so
einem punkt wo es um so ein
fundamentales gut wie die unversehrtheit
des körpers geht finde ich es richtig
dass es eine gewissensentscheidung
schuljugend keine kanzlerin
eine gewissensentscheidung ist jede
abstimmung im parlament
jede abdrücken muss immer nach seinem
gewissen entscheiden also diese wir
geben das jetzt frei auf das ist schon
eine geste von allmacht die eigentlich
nicht geht
gerade war es noch eine geste von oben
macht ja aber das ist ja oft verbal
allmacht real schwach oder wien und auch
kosovo wurde erste kriegseinsatz der
bundeswehr im ausland nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg dass wir auch keine kleine
sache also ich finde
jede position des legitim aber eine
regierung muss eine haben und auch als
regierung der kam fand ich der kanzler
zu spät sehen es vorhin angedeutet olaf
scholz hat lange gar nichts gesagt und
dann kam er mit der brechstange
sozusagen und das fand ich übertrieben
es war übertrieben oder das war schlecht
das im letzten sommer merkel das als
erster ausgeschlossen übrigens imst lich
wird es nicht geben weil man die
proteste vor dem bundestag hatte und
dann musste man das einsammeln aufgrund
ganz schlimmer zahlen hat dann olaf
scholz gehandelt aber dann hat er es
irgendwie offen gelassen und die idee
wir machen verschiedene gruppen anträge
und schauen dann mal hat das für mich
deutlich gemacht dass er irgendwie auch
hofft vielleicht wird ja doch alles gut
das war vor ort dann kam die grünen
diese neue variante von der wir alle
nicht genau wissen was passiert und ich
finde jetzt sind sie jetzt schulden sie
also der eine ministerpräsident aus von
der spd im norden verkündet eine
weihnachtsruhe die anderen sagen aber
wir können unsere tourismus städten
nicht schon wieder belasten und es gibt
keine einheitliche kommunikation vor
diesem weihnachtsfest sind nur appelle
ein paukenschlag mitte dieser woche war
ein interview von karl lauterbach dem
neuen gesundheitsminister in den ard
tagesthemen
wir haben also einen impfstoffmangel für
das erste quartal und den impfstoff
mangel zu beseitigen
daran arbeite ich bereits seit tagen ich
hoffe dass ich da in den nächsten tagen
eine positive botschaft übermitteln kann
aber in der tat also wir haben zu wenig
impfstoff und das hat viele überrascht
in der inventur mich auch erpresser die
botschaft hat viele überrascht passen
wollte er eigentlich verunsicherung
stiften um sie selber wieder auflösen so
historie hat ganz kurz vergessen dass er
gesundheitsminister ist ziemlich genau
aufpassen muss was er sagt und dass er
sofort auslöst zb bei den ärzten die
dann den patienten erklären müssen ob
ihr termin im januar eigentlich noch was
wert ist ob dann impfstoff da ist also
da zeigt sich schon dass gewisse
bedenken die es vorher gab ob er laute
aber wirklich der gesundheit der
richtige gesundheitsminister ist nicht
ganz aus der luft gegriffen sind ich
glaube dass er auch nur deshalb
gesundheitsminister ist weil es olaf
scholz nicht riskieren wollte irgendwie
erklären zu müssen wenn es schief läuft
ja warum habe ich nicht den karl
lauterbach genommen das wäre doch der
beste gewesen das ist einfach risiko
minimierung von olaf scholz gewesen wenn
es jetzt nicht funktioniert kann er
sagen das ist der einzige minister von
dem ich eigentlich gesagt habe den habe
ich genommen weil die öffentliche
meinung so war dass er sein muss und
wenn es nicht klappt dann müssen halt
einen anderen nehmen und vielleicht
werde man das sogar auch noch erleben
also diese ersten tage von karl
lauterbach man sich optimal mit dieser
anderen meinungen das ist der alte
kassensturz trick lehne jede partei die
drankommt verspricht im wahlkampf wir
machen wir geben aus und dann sagen wir
haben kassensturz gemacht es war so
wenig geld da und das ist der alte
kassensturz trägt er heißt jetzt nur in
ventura und vor allen dingen war ja
jemand zuständig ein vertrauter von
herrn scholz damals vizekanzler der
genau diese impfstofflieferungen
beaufsichtigen sollte das wird jetzt mal
vergessen was hat dieser mensch gemacht
bis dato also ich fand auch das war
nicht ganz glücklich der auftritt der
band ich komme auf die verunsicherung
auf die verunsicherung zurück auch auf
eine eskalation von protesten auch von
gewalt dazwischen gibt es eine große
gruppe von zweifelnden menschen die
nicht impfgegner sind aber sich immer
noch mit der frage beschäftigen was tue
ich eigentlich wie verhalte ich mich was
ist das richtige in dieser pandemie die
orientierung welche signale sende da die
neue regierung der neue minister erst
mal finde ich hat die regierung als
allererstes ein sehr klares signal
gesendet in dem oder chance gesagt hat
wir lassen uns das nicht gefallen damit
waren diese proteste gemeint damit nicht
gemeint alle müssen die gleiche meinung
haben aber proteste bei denen leute sich
nicht an regeln halten bei denen grenzen
überschritten werden bei denen vor allem
die grenze zur gewalt aufforderung oder
gewaltausübung stunde also das war nicht
da war er am anfang sehr sehr klar in
dieser meinung eigentlich und er hat
aber seitdem er hat ja so ein bisschen
kommunikationsprobleme der neue kanzler
und er hat ja da ist dann auch nicht
weiter verfolgt muss man sagen also das
war am anfang starker aufschlag und dann
kam nicht mehr viel generell muss man
sagen diese verunsicherung es gibt
natürlich auch immer so die idee die
impfung wird uns retten oder die eine
maßnahme da hat karl lauterbach gesagt
das ist glaube ich vielleicht nicht gut
auszuhalten aber es ist die wahrheit es
gibt nicht die eine maßnahme die das
problem beseitigen wird sondern das wird
immer eine kombination von mehreren
maßnahmen seien das natürlich keiner
sehr griffige botschaft wird die neue
regierung die ampel tiefer und weiter
spalten oder versöhnen
der riss der durch die gesellschaft geht
geht nicht durch die mitte sondern es
gibt einen rand der sich abgewendet hat
und den hat die ampel nicht verursacht
der war schon vorher da
und ich glaube dass man auch nicht
politik danach machen kann also mann
soll alle mitnehmen in der ansprache
aber was richtig ist muss schon
beschlossen werden und zwar unabhängig
davon wie viele demonstrationen wo sind
und deshalb finde ich es
impfen ist zentral und das muss eine
regierung sagen wenn der regierung sagen
würde dass ständig ortsgruppe und oder
yoga lehrerin an heimen dass das wäre
nicht gut deshalb glaube ich kann da
auch das argument der spaltung keine
rücksicht genommen werden ich habe auch
olaf scholz
so verstanden dass es nicht nur um die
gewalttätigen proteste gingen sondern
dass er schon klar machen wollte wir
lassen uns das wie das jetzt weitergeht
in der pandemie bekämpfung nicht von
einer radikalen minderheit diktieren das
meint glaube ich auch
ausgesprochene impfgegner die jetzt
nicht gewalttätig auf die straße gehen
und da ist dann tatsächlich die frage
hat er da die ganze ampel hinter sich
und da könnte man wenn man eben
äußerungen von herrn kubicki hört
zweifel haben ich glaube eben auch es
wird sehr wichtig sein dass dass die
regierung hier schon eine eigene
mehrheit in dieser pandemie auf die
beine stellt das kann einmal
funktionieren natürlich kann man
argumentieren das ist eine
gewissensfrage aber wie viele
gewissensfragen kann man jetzt in der
pandemie bekämpfung stellen also die man
muss schon nur die einen nur die eine
genau das ist die letzte das wird nicht
noch einmal das wird nicht noch einmal
funktionieren und olaf scholz hat ja
persönlich die verantwortung übernommen
er hat gesagt ich übernehme die
verantwortung dafür dass wir die
notwendigen maßnahmen treffen und das
muss er mit der eigenen mehrheit dann
auch hinkriegen er hat auch gesagt auch
herr lauterbach hat das gesagt dass wir
auf jeden fall diese pandemie beziehen
werden das ist ein hoher aber wann
etwas versprochen er hat etwas
versprochen was er nicht hätte
versprechen sollen glaube ich nämlich
dass wir unser altes leben so
zurückkriegen wie es war ich glaube das
wird länger dauern als als wir
vielleicht jetzt noch wahr haben wollen
so und versprechen das schon heikel aber
der ampel ist gelungen immerhin was den
anderen vorher nicht gelungen ist eine
impfpflicht durchzusetzen für
pflegekräfte im krankenhaus in
pflegeheim also es gibt fortschritte
aber ich glaube dieses große thema
impfpflicht wird die ampel aber auch die
gesellschaft schon in teilen zerreißen
auch wenn scholz immer sagt es gibt
keine spaltung der gesellschaft aber wir
merken ja auch im privaten in jeder
beruflichen diskussion spielt diese
frage corona impfen wer lässt sich
boostern wer ist gar nicht geimpft eine
ganz große rolle und diesen
gesellschaftlichen disput zu moderieren
zu steuern zu leiten das wird eine
herausforderung im januar sein bin ich
ganz sicher das heißt da ist ein thema
aufgerufen
das entweder zu weiterer spaltung und
unversöhnlichkeit führen kann oder am
ende wirklich klärt wie sich politik
positioniert in dieser pandemie wir
wissen dass noch nicht das wird
irgendwann im neuen jahr entschieden
zu diesem blog zur pandemie zum
abschluss noch mal die frage weil sie
viele unserer unseren user beschäftigt
die niederlande haben gestern wieder an
lockdown in kraft gesetzt sehr
kurzfristig wobei wir schon darüber
gesprochen haben lockdown ist ein wort
das viele interpretationen zulässt dass
es keine ausgangssperre aber ist eine
schließung von läden restaurants und
viele mehr hat jemand eine einschätzung
ob bei uns ähnlich scharfe reaktionen
auf ronny krohn zu erwarten sind
also ich glaube eine ausgangssperre
werden wir nicht mehr bekommen das kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen eine
weitere schließung von geschäften das
halte ich schon für möglich
machen wir einen harten schnitt der aber
nur zum zweiten problem zur zweiten
krise dieser regierung weiter führt herr
basler schau sie an weil sie jetzt in
berlin berichten für ihre zeitung aber
auch aus moskau berichtet haben der
aufzug von truppen an der
ostukrainischen grenze schon einige
wochen alt in dieser woche gab es einmal
eine eskalation weil das berliner
kammergericht
zusammenhang mit dem tiergarten nord von
russischen staats terrorismus gesprochen
hat berbalk daraufhin zwei russische
botschaftsmitarbeiter zu unerwünschten
personen erklärt hat wir haben am
wochenende am ende der woche auch
gesehen wie schwer sich die europäische
union tut damit sanktionen nicht nur
allgemein anzudrohen sondern auch
konkret zu sagen was sie meint mit ihrer
doppel sicht aus diesen beiden
standorten wie schätzen sie die
situation im moment an die lage ist
glaube ich wirklich sehr ernst es werden
ja nicht 100000 soldaten an der grenze
zusammengezogen
aus einer laune heraus und damit
werden wer wird etwas verfolgt entweder
tatsächlich
kriegsvorbereitung oder soll zumindest
der eindruck erweckt werden dass es
kriegsvorbereitungen gibt was ja auch
nicht schön ist das soll ja auch etwas
bewirken nämlich dass die andere seite
zurück weicht vielleicht konzessionen
macht die es uns nicht mal die sie sonst
nicht machen würde und insofern ist das
eine sehr sehr ernste lage und sie ist
auch für diese bundesregierung ernst
lage und für diesen bundeskanzler auf
den es schon an kommt nicht so sehr wie
auf den us-präsidenten vielleicht aber
natürlich schaut wladimir putin gerade
in richtung berlin ob europa ernst zu
nehmen ist ob ernst zu nehmende
sanktionen zu erwarten sind was passiert
mit nord stream zwei das sind alles
fragen wo es auf jedes signal ankommt
und da
kann man schon ein fragezeichen setzen
ob die entschlossenen signale die nötig
sind jetzt tatsächlich kommen olaf
scholz hat ganz klar gesagt
grenzverletzungen kommen nicht in frage
grenzen dürfen nicht neu gezogen werden
soweit es um sanktionen geht ist das
alles bisher noch unklar da kann man
jetzt argumentieren vielleicht ist es
auch besser dass er sich so klar nicht
ausdruck bevor er das erste mal mit dem
russischen präsidenten telefoniert hat
aber es wird eben schon auch auf klare
signale aus berlin ankommen und auch das
setzt die ampel schon wieder unter druck
weil
das hat sich ja schon vor der
bundestagswahl gezeigt die akzente
einfach unterschiedlich sind in der spd
bei den grünen auch bei der fdp
es wird auch zu sehen sein ob
bundeskanzler und außenministerin hier
tatsächlich an einem strang ziehen also
ich würde schon sagen das ist für die
für die ampel kein ganz günstiger star
als außenpolitisch ich glaube dass
annalena baerbock tatsächlich in den
ersten tagen der neuen regierung fast
ihren kanzler überholt hat sie hatte
einfach das glück es gab außenpolitische
treffen unter anderem in liverpool sie
konnte sich äußern und sie war sehr
dezidiert was china an ging aber auch
russland hat gesagt eigentlich können
wir nord stream zwei so nicht in betrieb
nehmen und das ist schon interessant wie
die beide vorpreschen aber scholz sich
in der außenpolitik vielleicht
klugerweise vielleicht weil das auch
noch nicht richtig kann bedeckt behält
oder bedeckt hält und sie aber doch sehr
forsch nach vorne gebe es gibt ein thema
wo sie schon auseinander gegangen sind
eigentlich das ist das thema nord stream
2 wo sie denselben sachverhalt sehr
unterschiedlich dargestellt haben olaf
scholz der gesagt hat das ist eine
unpolitische frage das entscheidet jetzt
eine behörde die bundesnetzagentur ob es
da jetzt eine ob seine genehmigung gibt
oder nicht und die aussenministerinnen
betont hat es gibt noch keine
europarechtliche genehmigung kein
europarechtlich einwandfreie genehmigung
ist derselbe sachverhalt aber sehr
unterschiedlich er hatte auf den
koalitionsvertrag verwiesen
dass können beide weil es trifft zu der
koalitionsvertrag regelt dass nicht die
bundesnetzagentur muss jetzt entscheiden
trotzdem ist das eine frage die zur
streit in der ampel führen kann und wird
nämlich dann die eu kommission muss hier
auch nochmal eine stellungnahme abgeben
die ist zwar nicht bindend aber wenn die
eu kommission eine negative
stellungnahme abgibt dann wird es ganz
sicher ein politisches thema für die
ampel und sollte es zu einem wirklich zu
einem angriff russlands auf die ukraine
kommen ich glaube dann muss man nicht
lange diskutieren dann kann auch nord
stream zwei nicht ans netz gehen die
kollegen
die kollegen haben völlig recht also die
äußerungen so wäre ein politisches
projekt ist ehrlich gesagt eine
frechheit weil wir sehen doch wie das im
erpressungs kalkül von russland eine
rolle spielt also das ist nicht gut dass
das noch so gesagt wird und das
interessante ist doch dass bei grün rot
eine verschiebung stattgefunden hat die
grünen früher die partei der
friedensbewegung haben ein realistisches
russland bild entwickelt und haben an
gefahrenanalyse gemacht und haben eine
idee von der geopolitischen antwort und
die spd die mal die partei von helmut
schmidt war hat mit herrn münster nicht
als fraktionsvorsitzenden jemanden wenn
er spricht denkt man das sind immer noch
die 80er jahre der sagt wir müssen
drohungen abbauen wo sind denn deutsche
drohungen gegen russland wo sind 100.000
bundeswehrsoldaten an der deutschen
ostgrenze hat angela merkel auf dem
roten platz jemanden erschießen lassen
nein das ist wirklich eine ehre neben
welt und da muss ich die ampel
entscheiden entweder diesen der im
koalitionsvertrag übrigens
erstaunlicherweise angelegt ist
realistischen russland kurs oder weiter
sozialdemokratische identität im geiste
egon bahrs frau hildebrandt ja man hat
den eindruck dass die ampel ein bisschen
hofft oder nicht die ampel sondern der
kanzler dass die bundesnetzagentur ihm
das abnimmt denn der fall dass russland
tatsächlich einmarschieren würde das
wäre ja
so schlimm und weitreichend das wäre in
dieser frage der einfache fall denn dann
würde sich jede weitere diskussion er
übrigens schwieriger ist eigentlich die
frage was wenn nicht dann muss man dann
kommt man nämlich in die bredouille dass
man sich da entscheiden muss der kanzler
hat natürlich das problem dass er auch
in der alten regierung war dir diese
position unter angela merkel immer
vertreten hat es sich hier um ein rein
wirtschaftliches projekt handelt und er
hat das pech dass er jetzt neu vermessen
wird denn das war ja auch einer der
vorteile grüne von merkel in
anführungszeichen sieg war diejenige die
putin am besten kannte die in am
längsten kannte obwohl sie sich auch
einmal sehr vertan hat als er dann doch
auf der krim einmarschiert ist was sie
nicht erwartet hatte aber insofern ist
das natürlich ein testfall da wird jetzt
deutschland auch wenn deutschland nicht
der wichtigste akteur in der sache ist
auch noch mal neu getestet er ist bloß
dem 2 0 ist das interessante dass er bei
dem zwar eigentlich noch hinter die alte
bundesregierung zurück gefallen ist weil
die kanzlerin ja ja es war ursprünglich
immer gesagt hat das ist ein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt aber dass
dann ergänzt hat ja gesagt hat laut
einer geopolitischen komponente das hat
olaf scholz jetzt weggelassen hätte auch
eine starke ministerpräsidentin genau
das ist ein stark man muss das so sagen
es ist ein projekt mit einer starken spd
geschichte dass auch mit gerhard
schröder zu tun hat und insofern sind
auch die bedenken zum beispiel in polen
wie es denn nun eigentlich weiter geht
sehr stark auf mit olaf scholz verbunden
weil er eben sozialdemokrat ist und er
muss dann schon zeigen dass er sich dass
er sich davon auch von interessen
vielleicht die manuela schwesig hat im
zweifel löst wenn es ernste
geopolitische andere interessen gibt und
man muss bei nordstream zwar eben eines
sagen da wird ja immer behauptet ja auch
russisches gas durch die ukraine fließt
oder oder durch durch die ostsee das ist
doch eigentlich egal meint das ist nicht
egal es ist wirklich ein
erpressungspotenzial man muss ja nur mal
vorstellen wenn nord stream 2 ans netz
geht sind wir dann in der lage zu sagen
wenn putin die leitung durch die ukraine
trockenlegt das machen wir nicht mit und
dann stoppen wir jetzt auch die dann
stoppen wir auch noch zum 2 nein das
sind wir nicht wenn das zum beispiel
zufällig im winter ist und wir auf das
gas angewiesen sind dann sind wir
erpressbar weil wir nicht in der lage
sein werden nord stream 2 zu schließen
ich glaube die pipeline mal ab da kommt
ein möglicherweise sehr großes thema auf
diese regierung zu christine lambrecht
die verteidigungsministerin hat in ihrem
ersten interview in der bild zeitung
heute gesagt russland ist der aggressor
das ist eine sprachliche klarheit die
man von den grünen zum teil gehört hatte
habeck hat waffen für die ukraine zum
beispiel gefordert
ich lese markt klinger fragt auch peter
muss die außenpolitik nicht genauer in
der regierung abgestimmt sein ist das
einsatz russland ist der aggressor der
leitlinie der deutschen außenpolitik
sein könnte der kanzler auch so sagen
würde ich finde da hat er einen punkt
denn genau dass diese vielstimmigkeit
bereits in den ersten zwei wochen
ist erstaunlich ist auch nicht gut in
der lage denn sind wir ehrlich ohne
corona wäre diese drohgebärde putins in
der ukraine die das größte thema was wir
alle besprechen würden was uns umtreiben
würde also es ist ja eine kriegsgefahr
die sehr sehr nahe ist auf einmal und
durch corona finde ich ist das immer so
auch das zweite thema ist dann dieses
und olaf scholz glaube ich ist
innenpolitisch sehr versiert man kann
ihm da nicht so viel vormachen aber
außenpolitisch glaube ich hatte er sich
wie alle sich auch immer auf die
kanzlerin verlassen die ja nach so
vielen jahren regierungen da wirklich
souverän durchgingen und die anderen
haben sich nicht beschäftigt von herrn
mas hat man wenig gesehen in den letzten
jahren und jetzt kommt es auf ihn zu und
jetzt habe ich auch das gefühl gehabt er
zumindest in der ersten woche sprechen
die miteinander wissen die was tief
sagen oder hat man noch nicht einmal hat
die spd eine klare position also ich
fand den satz von frau lamprecht jetzt
noch mal klartext und habe mich gefragt
wurde herr scholz so war es auch sagen
na hoffentlich weil das ist einfach nur
neue tatsachen beschreibung damit ist ja
noch nicht gesagt wie wir damit umgehen
aber ich meine man muss ja nur gucken
wer auf der krim der aggressor war dazu
kann es keine zwei meinungen geben und
wer jetzt die truppen zusammengezogen
hat das sind auch eine frage von
tatsache und nicht von meinung aber
tatsächlich glaube ich auch hier scholz
ist jetzt kanzler auch so politik wird
im kanzleramt geführt das heißt aber
nicht wir viele spd hoffen dass er frau
werburg sozusagen
eindämmt sondern dass er mal mit seiner
spd klartext redet all das in
mecklenburg vorpommern eine staatliche
stiftung mit russischem geld aufgemacht
wird um diese pipeline juristisch
möglich zu machen das ist ein skandal
wenn man sich anguckt was die russen
sonst in europa mit ihrem geld machen
woanders werden von den russen
rechtspopulisten unterstützt bei uns
sind das spd strukturen in mecklenburg
und das geht nicht und das wissen auch
ganz viele leute in der spd und da
müsste scholz einfach mal sagen das geht
jetzt nicht mehr die lage ist anders
schluss damit und das ist politische
führung in der bundesregierung und auch
in der spd die spd ist da ja auch kein
monolithischer block ich erinnere nur es
sein dass heiko maas tage nach der
position der spd dass heiko maas zu
beginn seiner amtszeit als außenminister
ja durchaus mit russland kritischen
positionen angetreten ist es gibt auch
andere in der spd die weit davon
entfernt sind
die gefahr durch durch putin
kleinzureden insofern ist es nicht so
dass olaf scholz da in seiner eigenen
partei keine unterstützer finden würde
er muss nur tatsächlich hier führungen
zeigen ich finde interessant dass er
nicht immer nur auf willy brandt
verweist was in der spd praktisch ein
muss ist sondern auch auf helmut schmidt
und da ist eben die frage was meint er
damit wenn er immer sagt willy brandt
und helmut schmidt helmut schmidt steht
eben doch auch für eine unrealistische
politik im kalten krieg und wenn das
damit angedeutet werden soll dann ist
das vielleicht ein interessantes zeigt
wir würden uns wünschen dass wir mit
russland friedliches einvernehmen hätten
auch ohne sanktionsdrohungen der würden
uns wünschen dass wir gute rezepte gegen
die pandemie hätten und wir würden uns
dann zurück erinnern an schöne bilder
wie das grün gelbes elfi und botschaften
von fortschritt und aufbruch die auch im
koalitionsvertrag als überschrift und
leitlinien formuliert worden sind
vielleicht zum schluss auf dieses
vergrabene verschüttete thema nochmal
einen blick und ich fange an mit einer
einschätzung des economist einer
britischen zeitschrift dort hieß es
letzte woche ist alles schwer auch nur
eine weitreichende reform zu finden die
eine der vier merkel regierungen
verabschiedet habe und der economist
bescheinigt uns an akuten mangel an
zukunftsfähigkeit beschreibt dass die
lage richtig
war ein mangel an zukunftsfähigen letzte
sozialreformen ist 20 jahre her die
letzte steuerreform ist länger her
sodass das und das muss man scholz auch
zu gute halten scholz hat ja in einer
regierungserklärung gesagt es werden
anstrengende zeiten und es mussten
schritt nach vorne gehen und das stimmt
und das ist dritte war das meine ich am
anfang als ich gesagt habe dass sie mut
dass sie sich so viel vorgenommen haben
das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht
schaffen können weil wir haben glaube
ich in den letzten jahren haben wir uns
immer sehr gut erklärt was alles nicht
geht und vor allem warum nicht und das
land hat sich so ein bisschen in seinen
bürokratischen
komplizierten verhindert werden von
außen alles immer bedrohlicher wurde und
frau merkel hat immer das signal
ausgesendet es ist alles schlimm und
immer schlimmer aber für euch wird es
nicht ganz so schlimm und das jetzt für
eine regierung in gestaltungsanspruch
hat und sagt wir glauben daran dass
politiken unterschied machen kann was
verändern kann das ist eigentlich gut
und auch wirklich in dem sinne wie der
economist das festgestellt hatten
wirklich ein wichtiges signal ja ich bin
gespannt ich finde bei der fdp zum
beispiel sieht man da gab es ja den
spruch lieber nicht regieren als
schlecht regieren und ich glaube jetzt
ist es lieber flexibel reagieren als gar
nicht zu regieren also dass ein fdp
finanzminister
ein nachtragshaushalt verabschiedet um
widmet mal ganz schnell dinge die gegen
die sie früher geklagt haben in
karlsruhe dass sie geschichten wie die
korona debatte jetzt auf einmal doch
sich irgendwie selber mit der
impfpflicht auseinandersetzen also ich
finde das erstaunlich viele flexibilität
gerade auf allen seiten da sind in der
neuen regierung und bin sehr gespannt
wohin uns das führt und ob uns das
tatsächlich dahin führt dass es die
dringend notwendigen reformen gibt oder
dass man sich doch ineinander verhakt
aber man konnte ja ich gebe ihnen noch
was mit nämlich eine äußerung des users
mit dem schönen namen wonneproppen der
fragt nämlich auf twitter wann beginnt
die ampel damit politik endlich zu
verändern was liegt aus dem
koalitionsvertrag jetzt bereits konkret
auf dem tisch oder gibt es doch ein
weiter so gut da muss man jetzt ein
bisschen verständnis haben weil jetzt
ist tatsächlich akut erst mal die
nächsten wochen pandemie bekämpfung
angesagt aber die dinge sind ja was zum
beispiel veränderungen in der
rentenversicherung angeht was
klimaschutz angeht windkraftausbau usw
die liegen jetzt auf dem tisch die
werden in den monaten in den nächsten
monaten in gesetzesform gegossen werden
müssen und ich werde gar nicht so
pessimistisch man kann sagen
flexibilität man kann aber auch sagen
kompromissfähigkeit also das ist ja das
was passiert ist in diesen sondierungen
und in diesen koalitionsverhandlungen
dass sich unterschiedliche parteien
zusammengesetzt haben was ist uns
jeweils wichtig und wo können wir eine
schnittmenge finden und das was jetzt so
ein bisschen abgetan wurde schlagworte
wie fortschritt usw
die sind ja vielleicht gar nicht
schlecht wenn diese drei parteien sich
dann hinter wichtigen reformprojekten
versammeln können und insofern
bin ich dann nicht bin ich da nicht
pessimistisch was mich allenfalls ein
bisschen vorsichtig stimmen würde ist
wenn ich mir die regierungserklärung des
kanzlers angehört hat habe ja da sind
viele projekte genannt worden auch viele
projekte abgearbeitet worden aber eines
war ja interessant er hat versucht die
bürgerinnen und bürger vor allen dingen
zu beruhigen das macht er ja mit seiner
sehr ruhigen art mit dieser ruhigen
stimme und grunde war die über folgende
botschaft fürchtet euch nicht es wird
sich viel verändern aber für euch wird
alles gut und das werden die menschen
natürlich testen also wird tatsächlich
absehbar in den nächsten jahren das für
mich gut
wird dieses versprechen eingehalten oder
erfahre ich in meinem persönlichen
umfeld und in meinem leben dass die
veränderungen hart sind und dass ein
höheres windrad mir vor die nase gebaut
wird zum beispiel ohne dass meine
bedenken gehört werden dann finde ich
das nicht mehr so gut also da kommt
schon problem die verbale merkel raute
vielleicht ja frau hildebrandt da sich
ja den den aufbruch oder sag mal die die
vielen versprechungen auch betont haben
ich greife das nochmal auf also wir
haben versucht aus der
regierungserklärung von olaf scholz
visionäre weitreichende setzte
herauszufinden haben wir jetzt nicht
gefunden die raute die sie gerade
angesprochen haben war ja im wahlkampf
auch das versprechen leute keine sorge
ihr müsst euch nicht auf große
veränderungen einstellen also mit mir
bekommt ihr keinen scharfen kurs der
irgendwo abbiegt wie passt das zusammen
mit dem tisch ich hab es ein bisschen
anders wahrgenommen also erstmal sehr
schwer bei urlaubs was raus zu hören
weil sich das ja alles auf einer sehr
flachen linie abspielt aber ich finde
das versprechen war nicht keine
veränderung sondern das versprechen war
stabilität
er hat noch nicht so richtig gut rüber
gebracht aber ich vermute das ist er das
was er sagen will trotzdem wird es
natürlich interessant weil man diese
ersten äußerungen sieht wie er auch im
kontrast zu christian lindner und robert
habeck die beide offensichtlich
wesentlich besser darin sind politik
nicht nur zu erklären im sinne von
sendung mit der maus was passiert hier
sondern welchen sinn hat das ganze und
welche zusammenhänge und das wird auch
sehr interessant sein wie er sich also
wie sich diese diese beziehung
entwickelt natürlich auch mit annalena
baerbock wo ich mir vorstellen kann dass
ich da konflikte mit christian lindner
noch ergeben aber ich glaube eben die
die idee war eigentlich stabilität und
veränderung ist ja schon das was der
koalitionsvertrag ganz stark an können
also jetzt haben wir das sehe ich sehr
an dass ich fand chance hat dann sehr
klassisch sozialdemokratischen
fortschrittsbegriff
nehme ich es wird besser es wird auch
materiell besser und es wird für die
kleinen leute besser dass das war ja
eigentlich das auf euren sich stark von
merkel unterschied merkel in ihrer
endphase war ja wir geben ein beispiel
durch die energiewende für die ganze
welt wir geben ein beispiel durch die
flüchtlingspolitik so ganz europa also
das waren immer globale aufgaben und
stolz auf den ganz normalen menschen
rekurriert hat auch noch gesagt es ist
übrigens auch okay wenn jemand nicht
akademiker ist akademiker sind nicht die
besseren menschen und das fand ich
erstaunlich deutlich und das hebt sich
auch sehr finde ich angenehm ab von
einigen was man in den grünen hört oder
auf den derzeit in der zeit liest wir
brauchen eigentlich in anderen
fortschrittsbegriff wir haben doch schon
genug wir müssen mal über verzicht reden
und wir müssen unsere unseren lebensstil
nur noch veredeln und das trifft glaube
ich die stimmung im land wesentlich
weniger als das was scholz adressiert
sind in den letzten minuten dieses teils
der sendung deshalb schluss frage wo ich
mich ein bisschen bei matthias rehfeld
auf twitter an lehne er fragt sinngemäß
woran ließe sich die menge an aufbruch
den messen ich habe mit der 100 tage
schonfrist angefangen und frag sie bitte
kurz zum schluss also woran werden sie
in 100 tagen 89 genauer gesagt die
regierung messen ob das wirklich zeichen
von aufbruch gibt an der bekämpfung von
corona wie wir dastehen dann und ich bin
mir sicher das erste gesetz wird das
mindestlohngesetz seien von hubertus
heil das wird im januar schnell kommen
weil das ist das zentrale versprechen
gewesen von olaf scholz für die kleinen
leute sozusagen das wird kommen und ja
dann bin ich gespannt was dem folgt ich
glaube die klimagesetzgebung wird noch
etwas auf sich warten lassen aber das
wäre für sie dann sozusagen ein grünes
häkchen das ist ein stück aufbauen das
ist zumindest ein versprechen
eingehalten das ist vielleicht kein
aufbruch ich bin mir sicher wir mit
corona da haben wir den aufbruch noch
ein bisschen verschoben wir müssen
erstmal wieder den status quo finden ok
ich will ja kein spielverderber sein
aber ich glaube es gibt eben keine 100
tage frist mehr das geht ab sofort und
tatsächlich ist corona das entscheidende
man kann über alles andere
energiewende und so da kann man dann
später drüber reden aber das ist alles
nichts wenn es jetzt nicht gelingt
das richtige zu tun in der korona
pandemie davon hängt tatsächlich so
pathetisch würde ich das sagen das
schicksal dieser regierung ab wenn sie
da scheitert was wir nicht hoffen wollen
dann kann ich mir eigentlich vorstellen
dass ihr irgendwas anderes gelingt weil
es darin um den kern von regierungs
handwerk geht genau weil es daher darum
das vertrauen in diese regierung geht
das sieht dass sie die menschen schützen
kann wenn sie das nicht kann wenn sie
daran in dieser in dieser pandemie
scheitert kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dass die menschen ihr bei anderen fragen
die auch kompliziert werden folgen
werden die regierung ist ja angetreten
wir machen nicht nur krisenbekämpfung
klammer aufwies zuletzt merkel gemacht
hat sondern wir machen auch was eigenes
und das finde ich erst mal richtig und
ich finde da muss man die drei partner
in ihren eigenen vorhaben müssen ich
fange bei den grünen an viel zeit haben
wir nicht co2 ausstoßen muss sinken
müsste er ist ja immer trotz aller
energiewende maßnahmen gestiegen er muss
wirklich sinken das müssen jetzt bringen
die spd muss die spielräume für normale
leute größer machen und die fdp muss
gucken dass der staat nicht so übermäßig
wieder hildebrand woran messen sie in
ich bin größer und sage 100 tage fristen
gibt es nicht mehr das ist altes denken
und ich freue mich dass 40 minuten
gedauert hat bis der kollege alexander
seinen obligatorischen seiten oft die
zeit ich habe noch nie auf die seite und
meine frau ist abonnenten ein falsches
beispiel weil die veränderung natürlich
nicht beim mindestlohn liegt sondern in
der klimapolitik ja team jetzt haben wir
teams gebildet zum schluss noch danke
für den ausblick gut dann gibt es
unterschiedliche meinungen ob wir jetzt
nach 100 tagen messen sollen oder dass
sehr viel früher tun sollten danke für
die spannende runde wir machen weiter
mit presseclub nachgefragt im radio bei
ddr5 im fernsehen bei phoenix und hier
in der ard das europamagazin mit dem
licht aus brüssel da geht es um die
korona bekämpfung in der eu die machen
es die anderen schön dass sie dabei sind
chips lassen sich gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt sich jetzt sind sie dran wir
starten mit sonja bilde in berlin
bekommen in der sendung vorbilder ja
guten tag meine frage geht ganz gezielt
eigentlich an den sohn alexander
zwei dinge dazu meiner sein ich wundere
mich total also briefe braucht führung
ja wo ist die führung und man kann sich
nicht auf eure 100 tage seither ausruhen
und tee trinken und mal hü und mal hott
und mal das wort fallen lassen und was
mich
verunsichert und ich denke viele
hin und her mit der außenpolitik ich
denke vladimir putin macht sich dann
riesenspaß draußen und deutschland das
nachsehen ich frage mich wofür
chefdiplomaten ja wo sind wirklich die
fähigkeiten auch aussagen zu vermitteln
und meine frage ich wirklich wo bleibt
die führung
ja wollen wir das als rhetorische frage
stehen lassen oder wollen sie eine
antwort wie sie möchten die frau will
möchte ja ich rate sei freiwillig ja gut
dann hören wir sie dazu alexander
sie beschreiben die eigentlichen zustand
über den wir schon gesprochen haben und
das weil in der korona politik so also
die ernennung von karl lauterbach und
gesundheitsminister und die ersten
maßnahmen die ampel parlamentarische
getroffen haben passen einfach nicht
zusammen egal von welcher perspektive
man das betrachtet da haben sie recht
muss scholz nacharbeiten und muss zeigen
was ist seine corona politik gehen wir
weiter danke schönen gruß nach berlin
aber vielleicht passt dass gerd horn in
saarbrücken was sie auf der seele haben
ihre sendung und wir endlich mal eine
frage an den herrn ganz in link von
jörn lauterbach hergemacht er wird
kritisiert weil er sich mal irgendwelche
äußert hat das zu wenig im stück da ist
und damals ein herr sparen
so gut wie gar nicht statt und diesmal
widersprochen hat der bruder
da redet man kann nicht rüber ich habe
eine zweite an der ganzen politik zumal
eine von allein nur als beispiel von der
familienministerin zum militär abgehoben
wird wir haben zu viele externe berater
die den staat viele viele millionen euro
kosten warum nicht fähige leute ein herr
lauterbach ist mir die zähne und ein
hahn taubmann nur als beispiel gerne
eine antwort von dem lernen das ist der
alte herr rösler genau der hat sich
schon vorbereitet danke herr nein ich
hoffe ich bin nicht über herrn
lauterbach hergezogen das war gar nicht
meine absicht ich habe nur an die
diskussionen und an die fragen erinnert
dies eben gab es ist ja olaf scholz
offenkundig auch nicht leichtgefallen
diese entscheidung zu treffen und eine
frage die es eben gab es karl lauterbach
ist sehr viel in den vergangenen monaten
jahren der pandemie in erscheinung
getreten in der öffentlichen debatte und
die frage war kann er kann er auch
verwalten kann er auch das
gesundheitsministerium führen und kann
er auch tatsächlich verantwortung für
diesen kampf übernehmen das muss karl
lauterbach jetzt zeigen und in diesen
ersten tagen richtet sich meine kritik
nicht daran dass er kassensturz macht
und schaut haben wir jetzt genug
impfstoff sondern ein bisschen wie er
das gemacht hat das ist zunächst in
einer talkshow passiert da gab es dann
viele offene fragen dann hat es zwei
tage gedauert bis es eine
pressekonferenz gab in der das dann
erläutert hat in dieser zeit gab es eben
eine menge verunsicherung und da würde
ich einfach nur sagen das war kein guter
start aber das ist jetzt noch kein
urteil darüber ob karl lauterbach ein
guter gesundheitsminister wird oder
nicht da wird er jetzt gelegenheit haben
das zu zeigen der zahn balhorn leider
verloren müssen das so stehen lassen
sonst hätte ich ihn gar noch mal
dazugehört
wir gehen weiter nach heubach zu klaus
schlumberger herrscht im lager guten tag
sie haben ein gerät an da müssten sie
das leise schalten ja und ich habe auch
schon live geschaltet fangen sie an er
schauen wir als platt
bezüglich der impfpflicht ich bin ja
kein gegner der ähnlich aber ich meine
mit den pflichten der zweite schritt vor
dem ersten schritt gemacht solange doch
keine registrierung vorhanden ist wie
will man das dann überprüfen oder wie
man das festlegen wer geimpft ist und
wer nicht dass er meine frage in die
runde
kann das jemand beantworten richtig es
gibt kein ins register kein zentrales so
wie es das jetzt in österreich zum
beispiel gibt und
großes versäumnis ich finde da haben sie
komplett recht und diese frage wird auch
im zuge dieser debatte kommen müssen um
die impfpflicht wie will man das
eigentlich nachweisen dass bitte
generalsekretär kühnert hat sich gegen
ein im register ausgesprochen ja der ist
ja auch bei der impfpflicht noch sehr
unsicher das wird interessant wie er das
mit herrn scholz aus diskutiert aber
rein sachlich müssen wir das offenbar
zusammen sehen ja also oder oder kann
meine gedanken einführen ohne ein
solches register ich habe ja auch ein
impfpass mit dem ich mich ausweisen kann
also ich finde das ist wieder so eine
deutsche datenschutz diskussion der
staat hat meine steuerdaten der staat
verlangt dass ich mich bis vor ein paar
jahren also hat man beim
kreiswehrersatzamt meldete und
untersucht wurde und jetzt wollen wir
eine pandemie bekämpfen und nicht wissen
wer geimpfte so war nicht geimpft ist
also dass das hätte längst beantwortet
sein müssen oder er ist lohberger dann
danke für den für den wichtigen input
ich bin hier noch gefragt worden wo
heubach liegt der telefonnummer nach zu
urteilen
irgendwo in baden württemberg einen
nürnberg im altmarkkreis im ostalbkreis
grüße dahin alles gute für sie und ich
gehe nach frankfurt das liegt am main
skihang deutschland ist in der leitung
guten tag erscheint bitteschön
montag gegen die runde ich hätte
bezüglich der endlich die runde die
frage das wird ja darüber diskutiert ob
die regierung machte als gesetzt oder
beziehungsweise gewissensfrage wieso
rückte die impfpflicht lich einfach an
die bürger weitergegeben eine
bürgerentscheid daraus gemacht sie
meinen eine abstimmung darüber
warum erschienen das sinnvoll na ja
wissen wir zumindest die politik auch
wie steht die bevölkerung dazu inwieweit
ist da sage ich mal die resonanz auch
gegeben in der mehrheit und dann hat man
auch diese diskussion nicht darüber muss
es eine gesetzliche grundlage dafür
geben oder zu fuß entscheidung der
[Musik]
ja also ich gebe mal die sachliche
antwort das ist bei uns so im
grundgesetz nicht vorgesehen sondern
moment ist es so geregelt dass der
bundestag oder bei manchen sachen auch
ein landesparlament das so entscheiden
kann ich nehme es einfach als impuls für
die debatte ich glaube wenn ich die
umfragen richtig verfolgt habe über die
letzten monate hin ist sehr stark vom
zeitpunkt ab da ist die reaktion in der
öffentlichen meinung immer auch sehr
stark einer auf die politische debatte
ich allein ich finde aber auch ein
schönes beispiel das zeigt warum es
sinnvoll ist dass wir solche
volksabstimmungen nicht durchführen was
bildet hier bringen
wenn das parlament sich in schlanken fuß
macht und sagt das geben wir jetzt mal
die bürger das ergebnis könnte man nach
den umfragen jetzt voraussehen eine
große mehrheit wäre dafür die dagegen
sind würden dagegen stimmen und die wir
der konflikt wäre nicht befriedet die
dagegen sind wären nach wie vor werde
nach wie vor unzufrieden ich glaube die
verantwortung liegt im bundestag und da
muss sie bleiben ok keine ergänzungen
danke für den für den impuls lieber erst
groß nach frankfurt und dann gehen wir
nochmal einmal eine runde über saarland
luise grammel wieder als abrücken
willkommen in der sendung programme ihr
thema ihr impuls ihre frage
[Musik]
ich bin
parteipolitisch völlig ungebunden und es
geht mir lediglich um eine
differenzierte sicht der dinge
erinnern wir uns also daran dass in der
nachkriegszeit
russland durch den warschauer pakt immer
eine biografische sicherheitszone hatte
und
russland hat ein
geopolitisches interesse dass die nato
nicht angegangen ist kein vergleich
und ich denke das ist einfach sehr
leicht nachvollziehbar und möchte sie
fragen oder und wie das komplett in
ihren überlegungen außen vor gelassen
haben haben sie jemanden bestimmten aus
der runde im blick
nein ok dann schaue ich mal ist um sich
alle so russland geäußert ein
berechtigter brand ja also das wäre
natürlich die frage für den kollegen
rösler aber ich würde einfach sagen in
dem fall ist der ausgangspunkt der
aggression so absolut sonnenklar die die
eu hält ja keine truppenübung ab an der
russischen grenze es gibt außerdem
sozusagen die frage wer wo mitglied
werden will das hängt ja nicht nur von
denen ab die schon drin sind sondern
auch von denen die rein wollen und es
kann ja kein grund sein dass russland
das nicht wünscht dass andere staaten
diesen wunsch nicht haben können aber er
vor allem an da muss man sagen die
militärische bedrohung geht im moment
ganz klar von russland aus und zwar
sowohl in dem was im moment sich
abspielt als auch in dem was da stimme
ich dem kollegen alexander vollkommen
sowas auf der krim stattgefunden hat das
ist ja keine ansichtssache sondern das
sind tatsachen also da würde ich sogar
preißler werden noch mehr anrufer zu dem
thema ich würde vorschlagen wir nehmen
alexander wittmann aus paderborn mit in
die runde wenn ich das richtig sehr
willkommen nach paderborn dann auch zum
europäisch russischen verhältnis
die kritik an putin
herr widmer sie sind in der leitung
montag fangen sie lediglich an buden
bildungspolitik ist auf jeden fall
berechtigt
wenn wie das gold note 2 jetzt im fokus
nehmen das ist ein wirtschaftliches
projekt welches vor jahren beschlossen
wurden ist inzwischen guten milliarden
von beiden seiten investiert das steht
schon bald
fertig und erst jetzt stellen wir die
frage wie das nutzen wurden oder nicht
ob das für ios ist
wenn sie auch den vereinen verkehrt
agieren wenn durch und plötzlich was
bauen lässt und dann die frage stellt
und abgesehen davon und wie die die
preise in unserem land anschauen und die
frage stellen wir wollen die energie
während der durchführung ist das
überhaupt
berechtigt ist es überhaupt möglich
sozusagen diese möglichkeit mit
lieferant von rüssel und was immer
übrigens in allen jahren sehr
zuverlässig war in frage zu stellen dass
widmer vielen dank wir haben ja viel
über das thema gesprochen herr was
vielleicht kann man es auf den punkt
konzentrieren also wie seriös ist ein
industrieland dass eine solche
investition
milliarden-investitionen zulässt und
dann auf der schlussgeraden sagt
pustekuchen der schau mal ob wir das
ganze in betrieb setzen na ja die frage
die man hier natürlich stellen muss ist
kommt die kritik vom himmel das kommt
sie nicht sondern die gab es von anfang
an das war von anfang an ein sehr
umstrittenes und eben nicht rein
wirtschaftliches oder
privatwirtschaftliches projekt ich
glaube man kann es nicht auch nicht als
solches hinstellen wenn man sich
in die russische lage versetzt da gibt
es keine rein wirtschaftlichen projekte
es ist immer auch ein geostrategisches
projekt und das war von anfang an klar
und die bundesregierung die damalige
bundesregierung wusste dass sie sich
damit in widerspruch zur europäischen
partnern begibt und dass sie damit der
ukraine auch größere probleme bereitet
und es war von anfang an klar dass das
dann zum schluss gerade in große
kontroversen geben würde also das ist
keine überraschung und tatsächlich es
kann könnte am ende sein dass der
deutsche steuerzahler zumindest
teilweise dafür aufkommen muss weil es
klagen geben sollten also im sinne von
schadensersatz das ist nicht
auszuschliessen okay er wird man danke
für den aspekt auch kurz nach paderborn
und in duisburg ist harald oft dabei
bekommen in der sendung
guten tag meine frage an frau
münstermann die vorhin den
nachtragshaushalt des herrn lindner
bewährt hat
glauben sie an die ernsthaftigkeit des
vorstoßes ich hatte zwar eine allee die
maßnahme denn das gericht wird ausführen
klimapolitik könnte auch durch
umschichtungen im haushalt finanziert
werden oder gar steuererhöhungen oder
durch ordnungs spricht verbots
also ich bin mir nicht sicher was das
gericht entscheidet aber ich bin mir
sehr sicher dass herr lindner das sehr
sehr ernst meint das hat er dargelegt er
hat es eine riesen riesensumme ich
glaube größer ist der verteidigungsetat
die man da mal so im nachgang
verabschiedet und mich hat das sehr
überrascht dass ausgerechnet christian
linder anfängt mit diesen
finanz architektonischen tricks
vielleicht ist es gerichtsfest das wird
jemand anders feststellen aber corona
hilfen mal schnell umzuwidmen in klima
themen halte ich für schwierig
hat mich auch überrascht ja danke ok
also der aspekt war wichtig danke für
die klärung
dann schauen wir mal liane launhardt in
wedemark
frau laune hat bitteschön
gewählt nicht wegen sondern trotz voll
gedächtnislücken 11 liege 20 alle für
english bekannt dies vorausgesetzt
erfolgte diese wahl bei vielen die pläne
in der hoffnung auf ein gutes kabinett
und da sehe ich mich mit vielen anderen
nun sehr enttäuscht weil von wieder
viele die stufe ihrer unzulänglichkeit
erreicht haben also das peter prinzip
bietet allen voran bei außen und innen
aber auch in anderen bereichen
ich bin da sehr skeptisch
okay ist eine meinungsäußerung die wir
stehen lassen
danke dafür
ja mag jemand vielleicht was noch zu der
frage sagen die sich auch hier durch
zieht frei hildebrand bayern lauterbach
ja auch gestellt wird also wie vielfach
frau oder fachmann muss ich sein oder
was macht mich eigentlich sehr gut
minister dann oder gut minister ich will
sagen ist kann auf keinen fall schaden
fachmann oder fachfrau zu sein aber es
ist nicht die einzige ist es nicht die
einzige hinreichende voraussetzung und
wir hatten ja im laufe der republik sehr
viele minister die fachfremd fahren und
trotzdem sehr gute minister geworden
sind ich würde auch erst mal sozusagen
den neuen jetzt die noch nicht
abschreiben ich finde chance hat jeder
verdient und bisher hat noch keiner
derartige böcke geschossen in den ersten
zwei wochen dass man sagen kann die
stufe der unfähigkeit ist erreicht wenn
es interessant war annalena baerbock
gibt es schon ein erhöhtes maß an
skepsis
man muss sagen sie hat sich in ihrem
leben immer mit außenpolitik beschäftigt
des glaubens und die letzte sieg in der
sendung tut mir leid bedanke mich
wünsche ihnen einen schönen vierten
advent gruß aus köln lassen sie es tut
geben
[Musik]
sie gelten als die helden der pandemie
krankenschwester und pfleger ärztinnen
und ärzte die helden behandelt fühlen
sich die meisten allerdings nicht die
zahlung des versprochenen pflege bonus
die wird ins neue jahr verschoben
schnell entschieden hat man dagegen die
impfpflicht für das personal von
krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen und die
kliniken zu entlasten muss die vierte
welle gebrochen werden darüber und über
die gefahr von omikron beriet heute auch
der neue chor ohne expertenrat und die
gesundheitsminister die haben
entschieden dass die testpflicht nach
der booster impfung entfallen soll aber
was hilft wirklich schnell den
operationen werden verschoben patienten
verlegt fachkräfte fehlen viel
versprochen wenig gehalten pflegekräfte
am limit unser thema in der phoenix
runde
phoenix